(gentle music)
- [Narrator] This satellite
image shows destroyed vehicles
scattered around the frontline
village of Novodonetske
in Eastern Ukraine,
which had a population
of several hundred people
before the war.
Russian state media shared a video
suggesting that a column of
Ukrainian armored vehicles
and Western tanks was destroyed
after running over a minefield.
The footage was released around the time
Ukraine's counteroffensive
started in early June 2023.
(explosion booming)
Kyiv says, "The sheer
number of Russian landmines
on the battlefield is
hampering its militaries push
to retake territory."
(missiles booming)
Here's how Russia created
one of the biggest minefields
in the world.
Ukraine's counteroffensive
focused on the Zaporizhzhia
and Donetsk regions.
Russian-held Novodonetske
is right in this area.
But Kyiv's forces quickly
ran into obstacles.
Russia spent months preparing
the 900 mile long frontline
with anti-tank ditches, concrete blocks,
trenches, and landmines.
It's estimated that
approximately 60,000 square miles
of land, more than 1/4 of the country,
may now be littered with anti
personnel and anti-tank mines.
(speaking in foreign language)
(explosion booming)
- [Narrator] Ukraine's Security
Council Secretary in August
estimated that Ukrainian
forces were encountering fields
with up to five mines per 10 square feet.
(missiles booming)
Videos shared online by
Russian state media journalists
and pro-war bloggers show
Russia's brand new remote
mine laying system known as
Zemledeliye or Agriculture.
First unveiled in 2020, the
system made its combat debut
in Ukraine in the early months of the war.
According to defense
intelligence firm, Janes.
Russian state media say the
system can set a whole minefield
three to nine miles away
using a single salvo of
50 mine loaded rockets.
Janes expert, the
journal spoke with, says,
"Zemledeliye is one of a
number of systems Russia uses
to literally sow the
frontline with mines."
(tank engine revving)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The minefield
slowed down Ukrainian forces
and channeled advancing
infantry into positions
where they would be an easy targets
for Russian helicopters,
artillery, and drones.
After losing a number of Western
tanks and armored vehicles,
the Ukrainian military switch tactics.
Now infantry are leading the advances
through the minefields on foot.
(speaking in foreign language)
(missiles booming)
- [Narrator] Military
analysts also say Ukraine
has been firing more artillery,
as well as using Western missiles
such as British Storm Shadows to target
Russian supply lines from afar.
(explosion booming)
The military experts with
Janes says for Ukraine
time is running out
before the weather changes
and large scale movements
become constrained
by the muddy ground.
In mid-August, Ukraine's
military made some advances,
retaking a village some six
miles away from Novodonetske.
This shows that while
Russian defense lines
remain a major obstacle,
they can be penetrated.
(gentle music)